bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors en quoi ce
cessez-le-feu ni fertile des autres
j'obéis coûté 7,7 guerre est arrivée je
dirais c'est assez subitement tout le
monde tous les acteurs internationaux
étaient un peu effaré de voir la
violence et la rapidité avec lesquelles
on est arrivé et donc je pense que la
piège était un petit peu tendue aux
russes dans toute cette affaire est
finalement j'avais dire ça se termine
bien pour les russes parce qu'ils sont
en train d'engranger pas mal de gains
dans cette opération
les azerbaïdjanais évidemment se sont
fait appuyé par les turcs
est ce que ce que je peux dire le plus
important c'est que pour moi ce que veut
dire ceci c'est que les accords de mines
s'affalait le groupe de minsk était
chargé normalement de lézards et
d'accords de paix et qui travaille
depuis dix ans à essayer de trouver une
solution finalement a été totalement
absent de cette de ce cessez feu et de
cet accord de paix et quand on voit
exactement tout ce qui s'est passé
quelque part en syrie la reproduction de
ce qu'on appelait en série les accords
d'astana entre la turquie la russie bon
là c'était la série pour pour l'autre
conflit est maintenant entre l'arménie
et l'azerbaïdjan
la série est là et la turquie est-ce
qu'il faut mentionner ce qui est très
important également c'est le rôle des
iraniens qui à mon avis se sont fait
très discret mais qui ont joué et ce qui
permet d'affirmer vraiment que cette
nouvelle orientation des accords de paix
style astana est en train de mettre en
oeuvre alors on à la fin des combats
donc mais qui ne veut pas pour autant
dire que la situation dans le haut
karabagh est complètement réglé ça reste
un territoire contesté sur cet aspect là
on en est ou à des écoutes et pour le
moment je pense que ce que les accords
de madrid qui datait de 2009 se sont
totalement réactualisé c'est à dire que
l'azerbaïdjan va récupérer tous les
territoires
autour du sac territoire là autour du
haut karabakh
je sais qu'ils ont trouvé un accord sur
le corridor de latchine pour pouvoir
pour laisser pour laisser le passage
entre l'arménie et l'arménie et le haut
karabakh
la ville de souche a évidemment a
évidemment est tombée la ville de souche
à ouvre ouvre vraiment la route pour
aller pour aller vers l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan donc si vous voulez ça y
est maintenant je pense que je crois que
les arméniens quelque part où on fait
une grosse erreur se sont crus fort
peut-être qu'ils se sont crus aidés par
les américains ils ont peut-être pensé
que l'europe volerait alors se courba
l'europe comme d'habitude a été de
frileuse comme bell les comme elle l'est
souvent dans ce genre de situation et
voilà donc maintenant cet accord signé
par les russes et les turcs je pense va
je pense que ça va j'espère calmer les
choses
calmer les choses dans la région ce
qu'on peut noter c'est que maintenant
les troupes russes seront présentes 3,3
territoire de l'asie du ce de l'asie du
sud l'asie de l'est
la géorgie elle est reprise vont être
présente en géorgie en azerbaïdjan et en
arménie
bon je dirais que c'est vraiment une
victoire pour pour poutine et c'est pas
très bonne nouvelle pour la kz américain
us israël autant pour le moment bon et
c'est très bien pour l'azerbaïdjan parce
que je crois que la population azérie
d'où les récupérer ses territoires qui
est killer qui leur était due si je puis
dire puisque aucun pays de la communauté
internationale n'a jamais reconnu le
haut karabakh donc j'allais dire
jugement il faudrait que ça en reste là
avec ça se termine pas trop mal voilà
apprécié à la londe merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes vice présidente de géo pragma
et chercheuse à l'institut prospective
et sécurité en europe merci